my name is Jeff Kimber and I I do come
from the visual effects industry I was
most recently the CD supervisor and I
speak via effects and clouds so really
happy to be here today I'm gonna be
giving a talk on google cloud storage
options and its kind of what it all is
when I when I joined Google I wasn't
quite exactly a hundred percent clear on
all the different storage options and
how they worked and why you'd use them
I'm also going to talk a little bit
today about getting your data to the
cloud and and how that looks so from a
google cloud storage option standpoint
Google Cloud Storage is a giant block
store so if you have on set data let's
say you've gone and shot a huge amount
of imagery on set and you want to put it
somewhere a standard storage is a great
place to put it it's it's super low
latency it's almost limitless in size we
also have and it's 2.6 cents a gig so
it's really inexpensive we have a less
expensive option for two cents which is
the durable reduced availability storage
so what does it mean to the VFX
community that that means that the
latency is increased a tiny bit that's a
really great place to park a significant
amount of data that you want to be able
to do read and write operations for if
you want to build a copy this data to a
file system you want to do the copy it
to local SSD on VMs which we'll talk
about in a few minutes if you actually
want to do transcoding or rendering
workloads against this DRA is a great
place to put the data we'll also talk a
little later about Nearline storage
which is our archiving solution and go
forward from there
as far as storage on the actual machines
go we have when you spin up a VM you
have a few different choices on on how
you want to get the data available to
the machine you want to run it on so
this slightly complicated diagram here
talks about persistent disk P D stands
for persistent disk it's network storage
and it's available both with enterprise
level spinning disk as well as with SSD
and we configure them in 10 terabytes
sizes we also have local SSD attached to
the machines and that is next-generation
it's super fast yeah think of it less as
a SATA option and more of a PCIe option
it's almost 700,000 I ops and it's 1.5
terabytes of capaz
so that's crazy fast instead of being
thinking it as fast disk we think of it
more as slow memory it's about speed of
ddr2 memory so if you want to deliver
something like a ZFS filesystem for
instance you can spin up a VM throws
that FS on it attached 1.5 terabytes of
storage to it and now you're serving up
1.6 to 1.7 terabytes of data at memory
speeds at line rate so that's what eight
gig per second on the filesystem you can
also attach 10 terabytes of PD to that
as well so that's that's a really neat
little file system that you can put up
which is open source and you're only
paying for the VM the different use
cases if you have raw camera data and
you want to you know perform transport
operations for instance on it you can
store it on on PD you can also copy it
over to local SSD so the use cases I've
identified here are transcoding fluid
simulations nuke Gazette if s read cache
so we have customers who want to do
fluid simulation in the cloud and from a
storage standpoint they'll copy the the
Olympic data and the scene data over
they'll do the the Nyad or Bifrost or
real flow fluid sim on it but they'll
they'll use the super high i/o
capabilities of that machine to be able
to write all the cache data so the point
is is that with local SSD you can get
really really high ops and you don't
have to worry about using any network
bandwidth to do it I've had as much as
30 percent of my simulation time be
eaten up by copying files across the
network to an ISIL on now that the
Isilon wasn't fast it was just that's
you know 20 to 40 gigs per frame of data
you're moving in that does impact
simulation times so from a network
connection standpoint we've talked
significantly about how many points of
presence Google has and how strong the
edge network is the bigger issue is is
as visual effects companies and media
companies how do you get your data onto
the cloud so there's several different
options we have we have customers who
light up dark fiber between their
location and a peering location for us
we have customers who will work with a
partner such as Soho NAT where they'll
buy a 10 gig interconnect and they'll
only pay for one gig to the outside
world but they'll be able to get a
much higher bandwidth connection to
Google and just pay a fractional
increase not what the full load would be
if you wanted to have that go to the
other side world google also has a VPN
offering which is a fully managed
solution which can deliver gigs of
connectivity the the nice thing about
that solution is you just tell us what
juniper or cisco box you have
on-premises or other and we have a
profile that works for it it's managed
it just works and if you want to run
commercial or private queuing software
that all works over the VPN it's just an
extension to your network so as far as
the transcoding workload goes so the
green represents your on-premises or on
set and this is a copy to Google Cloud
storage so you put it up on GC s and you
can Park all the data there when you
want to run a transcode workload on it
you can spin up VMS i'm using ffmpeg
just open-source we can also work with
panda stream and Zen coder local SSD is
is really kind of the secret sauce for
this because of the signature of the job
there's a huge amount of random reads
and writes that occur in the trance code
so you can spend about eight sixteen
thirty-two core VM and run multiple
trance codes in parallel and then you
can read all that data out to disk and
the local SSD will that will handle that
for you if you want to run more we have
customers who are using a product like
deadline or you can use pipeline effects
cube or tractor on your own queuing
system the cool part about that is that
the queuing system will spin up the VMS
copy the data from GCS over to the local
SSD unpause the job run the trance code
and then after the job's finished copy
all the data back in GCS which is here
and then spin the VMS down so you only
pay for what you use you can go
massively parallel with it we've had
customers who have you know five
thousand hours of content that they want
to transcode it's all in this example it
was all German and then you did to be
able to deliver it for distribution and
they were used to having seven to twelve
day delivery cycle and we said to them
well you know how many hours do you have
we got the file sizes and figure out
what the longest transcode was we're
able to deliver the job
in just over a day that was the longest
transcode so we just ran it all parallel
all at once and it was the same cost to
them whether it would be just over a
week or a day that was one of the nice
things about that so you've parked it on
DRA at this point so it's on durable
reduced availability storage so it's the
same system as GCS but I gained slightly
higher latency but you've already done
your copy you've already done the
transcode you've put it back to DRA at
this point you can push it out to the
network you can use one of our partners
like fastly if you need to use a CDN if
you just want to deliver it to a another
provider and they're gonna have all the
distribution this is your out now you
still want to of course retain this data
so now you can put it on your line so
the magic part within your line is it's
one cent per gig so again on the far
left hand side we've gone to from GCS a
2.6 to DRA at two cents a gig and again
as much reading and writing as you want
and then when you move it over to near
line that becomes a one cent per gig
place to store it and it can live there
as long as you want it to if you wish to
read that data back it's gonna cost you
one cent to do so so the nice thing
about this is that the data is available
to almost instantly the latency from
first read the byte is two to five
seconds so it's not hours it's just
seconds it comes back extremely quickly
I'll have a little slide with some more
details on that but we have customers
who will put their data in near line and
they'll bail they'll store it there if
they wish to do operations on it instead
of being worried about how many times
I'm going to read it and how many times
do I get charged at one cent fee they
just flip the switch and move it back to
DRA and it sits in D array and they
perform all the reroute operations
full-on on it for weeks or months
potentially I realized I can't give
historical data as your lines still very
new for us but those are the use cases
that we're using moving forward with it
so the compute engine we're running on
is it's really exciting for me in the
fact that it's crazy high performance
you are only paying for what you use the
real differentiator for us is the local
SSD performance for the transcode
simulation workloads from a storage
standpoint this previous transcoding
slide that I had
it's the same work case if you want to
run nuke jobs for instance if you've
already rendered the image in the cloud
it's there and you parse the nuke file
when you submit it through your
scheduler only the elements that have
changed are going to be uploaded and
you're able to benefit from the super
high output of the local SSD drives that
are physically attached to the VMS so we
have customers who are using nuke on
this we have customers who are using
fluid sims they have for their
proprietary fire systems that run on top
of our systems and again all of them are
using this really high i/o storage and
what it does for them is saves their
on-premises file system which I'm sure
if anyone has run large rendering
systems where you have you know tens of
thousands of cores and you have a
significant amount of compute happening
if you load your file system up with a
large amount of i/o for a fluid sim or
any other type of simulation or
compositing workload with deep data
where you're looking at an order of
magnitude more data per per element
you're in a scenario where that file
system forms can degrade and then you
start starving out your CPUs and as soon
as that happens you have to start
throttling one and favoring and other
and such if you move the higher
workloads to Google cloud platform you
don't have to worry about your file
system performance on-premises you can
focus on having 100% of your machines
running renders or a smaller percentage
running comp and sim jobs but you're not
a negatively impacted by that so as far
as Nearline storage as a slide goes this
details a little little bit more of the
relevant information so it's it's one
cent per gig to store it which is super
inexpensive it's one gig when you read
it so again if you want to read it more
than once or if you really intend to be
doing operations on it you want to put
it on DRA at least or GCS depending on
your latency needs we have customers who
are excited ok here the one set and
they're like well ok so everything's one
set now like well no it's it's really 2
cents if you want to do operations on it
in one cent if you want to park it
somewhere there's a one-month minimum
charge to put it there so it's it's
priced in such a way that it's not
intended for production workloads but
it's priced in such a way that it's
intended to be used for ultra long term
storage another nice aspect of being
able to use an airline is an archiving
versus tape is you're gonna make two to
three copies on tape and then you have
to transport them and store them and you
had to pay for the robot and someone to
run it and then you have to track and
manage and do it with all of this the
the nice thing is you can modify the
size of the footprint of the data that
you've put on Nearline so if you take a
four hundred terabytes showing you need
to put it somewhere then you can throw
it onto an ear line and then you can put
up a pipe technical assistant on it to
go through and look a shotgun and figure
out what can stay and what what doesn't
have to and you can reduce the size of
the show I've had shows that were 400
plus terabytes and we've reduced them
down to 225 terabytes on disk because of
course we don't we didn't back up the
temp files obviously but you go through
and you figure out you don't need 17
versions of character X and and you
don't need a whole bunch of temporary
Maya Mari archives that that were that
were 2 and 50 gigs a piece you can go
through and say we only use these two
and these these were live and these were
the latest versions so the ability to
change the footprint of the archive
really affects the the long-term storage
cost as well as the organization of the
project so you can see it's super high
durability the retrievals are fast
they're only a couple seconds to get the
data back I'm sure everyone here has
done restores or made restore requests
and you've had you've waited anywhere
from a couple of hours to go and get
that tape and loaded in the robot and
restore like a 20 gig character archive
and then you realize oh well that
texture was actually bored from over
here so you have to do a second pass to
get the data back or you've restored a
significantly larger portion than what
you needed because you want to make sure
you got it all the nice thing with this
solutions you can traipse through the
file structure grab the files you need
and bring them online right now and the
fact that the more you store the higher
the throughput is so those customers
with large pipes if they have hundreds
of terabytes or petabytes of data store
they have a significant through point
it's predictable and they know what the
cost is going to be and our API is our
known from a a pricing standpoint both
the compute and the storage have been
heading down with Moore's Law so youyou
can see our curve from 2006 to 2015 it's
it's continuing to go in in that
that direction so customers who have
been using our our Ivy Bridge technology
we've rolled out as well in a number of
our zones and we're continuing to update
and refresh our hardware in that context
you're able to get the increased
performance at not the same cost but at
a lower cost as we continue to reduce
our costs as well as increase our
storage capacities and availability so
from a just an overall use case
standpoint with Google Cloud Storage
most customers here are going to be
putting their data on GCS from an upload
standpoint and parking it there and then
they're going to be spinning up VMs as
file systems and they're gonna use that
FS or they're gonna use a veer or
they're going to use Gluster a veer is
here to talk today they're a fantastic
solution that most everyone in the room
knows about they have it on Prem our
cloud offering is excellent you can have
between 3 and 30 VMs and it can scale
larger than that you get to use our fast
low latency network fabric and you're
able to use our persistent disk SSD
based for the backend storage so you
were able to serve up file systems that
are capable of having tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of cores point
out them simultaneously and be able to
deliver that that throughput that you
need and a really high read rate it's
also very nice to be able to have
something like a veer and the fact that
you can use it as simply a caching
appliance so you don't have to
pre-populate it if you don't want to you
can spin it up and read through it and
then the data is cached for hit rates
are high for smaller jobs that are
potentially hundreds of machines you can
point out is that FS file system and
beyond left or the engineer who did our
ZFS file system is is here today to
answer any questions you may have about
that he's in the blue shirt at the back
of the room waving hello it's it's
exciting in the fact that he can stand
up to hundreds of machines hitting it
it'll deliver eight gig per second all
day long and as I mentioned before it's
backed by our local SSD you can also
have multiple set of s file systems so
you have your texture on one and you can
have your alum mcdhh Atta that turns a
little bit on the other and you can
point multiple mount points at it so
feel free to come in and talk with me
after or Bjorn about some of the
different the effects were glows for
storage
happy also to answer questions you might
have about getting the data into the
cloud just to wrap up here putting the
data on GCSE spinning up a file system
to build one compute loads against it
once you've completed your compute loads
if you're on a file system you can put
it back on GCS to park it or you can
copy the local SSD data back to GCS and
then you can spin your filesystem down
if you don't have production workflows
to run the final you can use on network
to deliver the data and then once the
show's wrapped you can take the data as
you've been filing the shots you can
move it off to nearly and the entire
show can sit on your line for as long as
you want it to and yet you can bring any
assets back online in seconds to be able
to get at and I think everyone can agree
that that's a really useful use for for
storage being able to get at a show from
six or eight years ago and be able to
pull those assets online